foreign
people have been asking hey what's going
on with taxes this year what's changed
what do I actually need to know can you
just give me the facts yeah well let's
talk about that we've got five things
here quick details number one guys you
can start to file your taxes early you
do not need to wait until April you can
start by the end of January so get it
done early the filing deadline is April
18th but you do not need to wait until
April 18th okay you don't want to be
scrambling and scratching now if you do
need to file an extension the deadline
to do that would make your filing
deadline October 16th so make sure to
get that in uh George what we got here
we got the standard deduction so that
increased it's 12 950 for single filers
and 25 900 for married couples filing
jointly and that's a good thing because
that reduces your taxable income which
means you're paying less in taxes that's
right and partially you know thanks to
inflation which income tax brackets also
went up in 2022 to account for inflation
they did and guys we want to warn you
about scams watch out for this because
you you'll get people coming out of the
woodwork talking about tax relief debt
consolidation scams and I want you guys
to know you might come home to emails or
uh phone calls voicemails text messages
or anything of people saying that
they're the IRS they are not the IRS the
IRS will only communicate to you through
the snail mail that's right not even
email it's only if you get a letter in
the mail from the IRS so if you've got
voicemails if you've got anything like
else like that it's a scam and always
check the IRS website for the phone
number if you do get something in the
mail it's a good way to double check
that's right don't just call back any
old number and start handing out your
social security number yeah you can
Google those numbers and it will tell
you if it's a scammer yeah so that's a
great reminder for one of our listeners
there another one the IRS was warning
people to wait for these 1099ks but
that's on pause so false alarm and if
you're wondering what the heck the
1099-k is well there was a tax code
change that would have mandated uh
Declaration on any exchanges over these
payment apps like PayPal venmo other
cash apps if it it was over 600 bucks in
exchanges they wanted their cut but
they're waiting they're going to kick
that can down the road yeah for another
year so you don't have to worry about
that which technically they're entitled
to the taxes but I'm just saying anyway
smaller refunds the IRS warned people to
expect smaller tax refunds this year
guys in 2023. think about it we were all
used to that 20 20 money you know what
I'm saying but there were no economic
impacts thank goodness in 2022 so
taxpayers will not get an extra stimulus
payment in their 2023 tax refund check
so I know that y'all y'all were used to
getting that money but it's not gonna
they had all the expanded tax credits
and deductions like the child tax credit
charitable contribution deduction but
now it's all reverting to the
pre-covered movement so yeah that's a
good thing that's tax dollars all right
number five stay away from Advanced
loans I cannot say it loud enough do not
take out a loan for your tax refunds
these ads are everywhere and uh I'm
gonna call them out by name H R Block we
see you we see
we see you we see you trying to Peddle
loans to people for these we'll get your
refund now we'll give you a loan for it
and I'm mad about it we've already look
you've already loaned your money
tax-free and interest free to the
government all right interest free
you've been giving them your money every
paycheck and now they want to turn
around and offer you a loan for your own
money don't don't do it don't take the
bait just wait and get your refund all
right that's all we need to do so I want
you guys to know that we've got you
covered as far as all the resources that
you're going to need for this tax season
head over to ramseysolutions.com
taxes you're going to find everything
that you need for this 20 23 tax season